Hey there.
Hello young man, how are you?
Hello.
Look at you with the facial hair, I thought you had grown.
- Yeah, where'd you get that idea?
I thought I saw like it wasn't positive.
it was you, but there was pictures from the broadspire like
conference thing. I was like that looks like Spencer but he's got
like a goatee.
- I've never seen that before.
It looks great.
- Except I can't, I can't.
I'm not quite as much of a man as you. I can't grow that
Big, thick, crazy view.
Dude, dude, like I don't even sure you want it.
Like it's a pain in my ass.
- No, seriously, 'cause I...
I took a vacation up to the Pacific Northwest.
And while I was gone for two weeks,
and like by the time.
time was over.
Like this thing was like down to here, I had this like big like
like devil looking thing and then
This was all scruffy and shit.
Like I paid a guy 100.
box to like to fix it.
and shave my head and every day I was just like I gotta take
I can't get any more.
Nice, I love it.
And you have a newly shortened.
and look as well.
- Yeah, I do, yeah.
I honestly, I just wasn't getting my...
Now master the barber enough to like.
actually take care of it.
So I just started shaving my hair.
It just does it. Yeah, you don't know third.
So you're doing your own business and everything.
How's that going?
Yeah, I'm out. I'm out of the W-2 thing.
I'm just doing it by myself now. It's-
And how does it-
It feels extremely liberating.
Yeah, yeah, it is.
It's been great.
And not just because I'm--
I left a job that I didn't like but like this this is
what I should have been doing the whole time.
Now I can see that, I can see that. Yeah, I think you're a little too.
to be independent or to be independent.
a cog in a wheel, right?
I'm an independent
I'm like, uh, what's her ass from, uh...
I'm Mary Tyler Moore.
Exactly. And you.
Yeah, and I part of it.
Part of the momentum around that was getting the notation.
Chandler.
Really?
Yeah. So that's not surprising. But where do you...
you meet him. I just saw what
Like, I was learning more about revenue operations.
or rev ops or whatever, and I search for you.
in LinkedIn for one reason or another.
And then
like he came up, I was already connected with him.
Okay.
And that was just one of the...
things that he had listed for like his Packard Collective.
like thing that he's doing.
- Right.
- And so I just reached out to...
I've been hearing about you for years.
And like, let's, let's chat.
So he and I have talked a couple of times,
like we are very--
dissimilar in terms of how we think.
do when. Because it seems like he was a little...
Unstable. [laughs]
I think he like me struggling a little bit.
I think he yeah he eluded
And I think he is kind of...
He has stabilized since that was happening.
and a lot of that's going to be.
Diego? Yes.
Yeah.
He's in San Diego and a lot of what has
been his path is kind of what I've been trying to do which is
like he is very focused on.
how the workforce is changing because of artificial intelligence.
interesting. The way that she...
he is going to market is
It's it's not identical to what I'm gonna be doing, but
but it's basically like, if you are a knowledge.
worker. If you are a white collar knowledge worker who
uses a computer for your job.
- Right.
70% of your job can be automated.
Sure. And like,
That's at least the direction that things are going.
And so...
what he at least is like
It's client wise not sure, but what he wants to do.
is he wants to get to know with other like
minded people who are like on that same way.
We've learned about how things are changing.
to learn about like how you can.
and put a business model together around supporting or--
organizations that are not up to that speed.
and be able to provide guidance.
to them on like this is how to
code like this is how to be
in the AI ecosystem beyond
just getting your emails written for you by chat,
you PT.
That's--
like where he's at at this point. Got it. So, so.
insulting kind of stuff. Yes, that's that's what he
is doing and that's what you're doing as well.
Yeah, I'm pivoting into doing console
still focused on business development.
primarily but um all.
Also executive coaching with salespeople.
And yeah, and it all has to be.
to do with I have learned how to do things with artificial
intelligence that far exceed anything that I thought I was
capable of doing. And I want to be
able to like there's a
a storm coming Spencer. I'm happy to hear that you
are trying to get out of the workforce sooner rather than
than later, hopefully with lots of liquidity.
Try.
- Right?
(laughs)
- Well, have you?
It's happening baby. Yeah, yeah
I put my notice in. Do I not tell you that?
Yay!
Let's take a second to talk about that.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, yeah.
So Sunday, Sunday.
Last Sunday not yesterday, but last Sunday
I just, it just the no.
knowing just became very clear that it was time.
So I sat down to my computer and said, "Mark, it's time."
And so last week was a little bit of
of a, you know, like it's been a mind fuck quite often.
Honestly, I'm sure because it
This is... this is a...
major transition in one's life.
You know, I'm watching a lot of videos and stuff.
I wanted to be...
I was reminded that yesterday was.
There's sort of no going back, right?
I mean, retirees go back to work.
work and whatever.
I get you though.
You know, you step out of the job for a couple of years.
Nobody's going to--
to say, hey, you want to be a VP now?
Because now you're--
relevant. So, you know, now you can be like a greeter.
or call yourself a consumer.
or whatever. (laughing)
going to hire you, right, kind of thing?
Seriously.
Because like I saw, what's his name?
Bob Martin.
I saw him do that. Like after he got laid off.
He was like, "I'll do consulting."
I don't think anything ever happened because--
No way is buying what is--
old and you're sort of irrelevant.
So anyway,
So there's sort of that, you know, oh my God.
But this really is a reinvide.
So that's the...
a little bit. Yeah. I'll get on my mind, but.
Yeah, so, so, um,
It's terrible timing.
Terrible.
timing because Mark just got elevated to have a
all of sales for the entire country.
you know on both sides of the organization.
He was
getting ready to promote me into VP of operating.
sales operations. I just don't have it immediately.
to do it, not interested. I'm tired of some of the people I can do.
I hate half the people.
I just feel like I'm being sort of
of, you know, taking advantage of constantly.
And I'm just getting resentful and kind of crouching.
So it's not, it's time for me to move on.
But so I did tell him that.
I'll stick around long enough to kind of, you know,
transition somebody. But we have
We have a nail down what that date is.
Yeah. So, yeah. So I, I,
No, but I told him I don't want to be here longer than like my
10 year anniversary is mid April right and I
I certainly don't want to be here to my birthday, which is end of June.
because I need to be my brother to retirement.
That's what this is all about.
Absolutely. That's it.
What other motivation is there other than?
Sibling split I totally get you
Totally. Totally get it. Yeah. Wow.
Well, I mean like great because the last time
I talked to you. It's not that it was radically different, but it like
Like, you have now made that shit.
like that the kind of you've crossed the roof
So is there a story?
story behind that, like did something happen?
Was it this fucking conference?
that you were just saying, you were like, I'm out.
No, no, it's it's been
- I mean, I've been working on this for months.
It's kind of-- - Yeah.
because like Vicki was totally taken off guard.
although she clearly wasn't listening because I don't.
been hunting for a long time.
But like, I mean for the last--
Last six months I've been having garage sales.
I've been selling stuff I've been...
and giving stuff away.
My house is empty.
I've been sort of thinking
through a, you know, like a put together project plan. I did.
Like, I did the whole...
Chen Ching-Bt, I'm so worried about this.
I don't know what to do.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm BN Bobo Bobo, put it in and it said,
here's your project.
I took a TINA.
Timmy Samenza on that one.
And did that, which was really helpful.
Yeah, so it's been a long time coming, but...
I, you know, I think I told you, well, I know I told you my
story about leaving Albuquerque that I kept getting this image in
my head of me as a kid holding on.
not willing to open my hands for what's better.
These days, the image that's coming to my heart.
It's so weird because I'm not I'm sorry
sounding religious these days.
But the image that's coming to my head.
is me standing in front of a doorway.
and there's a bare white wall closing an army.
And it's pushing me toward that doorway.
And there's
There's nothing I can like I'm being compelled forward.
And in that doorway, there's a monster.
And he's very menacing and sort of waving and coming
about. And as I get closer, I see that it's simply a block.
and that...
with the waving, I can see that.
Laund it.
So it feels like there's a, it feels like this.
This is a threshold.
This is a, I have to do this.
this. And it's it's.
It's a little scary, quite honestly, because, you know,
like I wake up and I'm like, well, what if my money goes away?
way and you know that kind of thing.
But...
that I'm also sort of reassured that I need to make.
this step and things will be fine. I'll be good.
And then one more other quick.
thing was the last, I don't know, several months.
I've been working on finding a new finding.
- Long story, but like the last guy.
It just, things weren't working out.
Okay. So I found a new model. I found a guy that charged me.
a flat fee. So I'm getting a
bargain. So since nine assets under man.
management? Yeah, because assets under management gets really expensive.
And there, and then your incentives are not.
aligned because now their incentive is
to caution you to not spend your money.
because they make more money, the more money you have.
- Right.
then it's just it's not set up. So
So there's a new model or real--
not--
a newer model of withdrawal.
And it's called the
the Gargoyle system. So basically,
it's this whole mathematical thing.
that instead of the 4% rule, you
which the 4% rule is based on the market.
is 1929. Things suck. You can withdraw.
off 4% and live forever. You'll be fine.
Well, the market is not
The market the last several years has been.
ridiculous. Yeah. So in this.
in this kind of an environment, you can take
I don't know. People are saying six and...
10%, which I would...
be afraid to take.
Because that would feel like you were really shooting.
yourself in the foot. Right. Yeah. You're cleaning the house. Yeah.
Yeah, but so I found a guy that
works that model and
Actually, I met him in person in Tampa.
So yeah.
Nice.
and Tampa. And when he showed me...
When you showed me how much I can spend in retirement versus
much I'm spending now.
I was reassured that I'll be okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah
Yeah.
Yep.
That's good.
I'm in the process of moving to South America, so.
It's not gonna cost me anything.
It's super deep over there.
Right, and like that.
That was pretty much always the plan.
- Yeah, Columbia, you said?
- Yeah, yeah, so what?
What I'm going to do is the first, I don't know,
weeks anyway I'm going to go to Australia and
maybe poke around Asia a little bit and I don't know.
bally or whatever. And then, and then I think
I think I'm gonna go like, you know, go to mid...
a month, get an Airbnb.
because I'm familiar with Medellin.
- Right.
And then, you know, from there, I'm kind of thinking,
you're going to just something.
but then by then it's going to be winter, so that's not going to work.
you know, because other side of the equator.
Right.
And I want to spend some time waiting for those holidays.
I want to spend some time.
I'm in Uruguay.
And I don't know. Yeah, just yeah
idea where I'm in the land. I don't know what's gonna happen.
It's a little freaky, but...
You know, that's fine.
Have you ever...
Have you taught to anybody who's...
done something like this before.
- Yeah, so remember.
Steve? The name sounds familiar.
The guy that moved to China.
Oh, OK.
Yeah, he's been there for 12 years. Nice. Okay.
- Yeah, so.
No, and I was.
I'll mention this too because this might be helpful.
for you in your business.
So you know the guy that wrote the four hour work week.
Yeah, I've thought about him a lot lately.
Right, right.
Are you familiar with this fear setting exercise?
No. Okay, so I was aware.
that thing existed. I looked it up this weekend because I
I was like having sleepless nights.
I was freaking freaking out.
- Yeah.
And his spear setting exercise is you do three columns.
The first one is you write down all your fears.
The second, and so I have this like I am convinced.
that I'm going to be violently robbed and sort of let me know.
left for dead. And, and.
It's somewhat irrational, but it's not.
It's not outside the realm of positivity. It's not completely crazy
Yeah, it's okay, but I mean Columbia, right?
Right. So, a reputation. Yeah, exactly.
And, you know, I'll be careful and whatever.
But then...
And so the first one is all your fears so you just list out like
in painful detail, all the things that are fucking freaking out.
in the middle column you list, what can I do?
prevent this from happening. And then in the last
column you say what what could I do to recover if this does?
happen. And so Tim Ferriss, he says that
that doing that has helped him do.
in his business decisions.
So it's sort of that.
Oh my god, like I didn't think about this
and what if like nobody comes and what if right.
Now too many people come and what if my price
is wrong and what if on and on and on and on.
Right.
You know, what if they hate my brand?
What if they, I don't know, they think I'm too young.
What if they,
I'm too old, but you know, whatever. Right. And then, and then,
you just work through those things.
And doing that,
weekend. Help me to make some connection.
that I wouldn't have made otherwise.
It helped me to put together some contingency.
some that I hadn't thought of.
Right.
Like okay, I get it. I'm old but like I have
thought to like take pictures of
like have electronic versions of like
my birth certificate, my passport, my driver.
My voter registration, all those things.
so that when I get robbed and left for dead.
that I can go to like the local embassy and say
Help me and they'll hook me up
So nice stuff like that.
Yeah, no, that's that's brilliant.
And when you're when you're looking.
- Yes. When you're like...
like not only retiring, but then also
doing this big thing. I mean like is
too much. It's a lot and so I'm glad
that you are finding ways to kind of mitigate.
some of the too muchness of it because it's too much in the sense
of like that's a lot of change at once but if you break it down.
and the way that you're talking about, then you can
Nationalize away a lot of the enormity of it.
So yeah, no, I love hearing about it.
But, and I'm selling my house and I'm selling my truck.
selling everything I own and I'm gonna have a bag.
Yeah. So it's
It's funny because I was freaking out this weekend.
And co-pilot was like, you know,
maybe you should think about it.
building a bridge, you know, like do this one.
incrementally rather than you know and I was just
just like, no, fuck you, you're wrong.
It's finally, I'm not gonna jump if- if-
There's a bridge, like I need to jump.
I know myself. Absolutely. Absolutely.
I even asked my money guy.
I was just like,
What if I chicken out and just want to stay here?
And he was like, "Hey, you're fine.
You can stay here too if you want to."
And I'm like, no, wrong answer.
(laughing)
to yell at you and be like don't be a pussy just do it now
Exactly. Exactly. Thank you.
Good, yeah, no, it's good.
It's good to know, like, what kind of motivate.
in order to be able to
like make that jump. It's not fear-based mode of
It's a I want this to happen
at once rather than like dragging
my feet and screaming into the...
change. You just want to bite the bullass, right?
So the second part of his exercise is, what are the benefits?
of doing this. And when I say the benefit,
of doing this. I'm like 20 years from
now. I'm really proud of myself. Yeah.
I'm gonna look back on this period with
pride and great memories.
- Yeah.
- You know, all that great stuff.
And then the third piece.
of it was what are the what are the.
What's the impact of not?
doing this. Yeah.
in three months in one year and three years.
And I started writing that stuff and I was just like
I simply cannot do this. I simply can't.
cannot go on, hence the wall pushing me forward.
I just I can't face another day. I mean I can
another day. But the thought of
of having this sort of open end.
I'm here for the long term.
Right.
I just can't do it.
The way that you just put that is very similar to...
what I had said to Nikki about like when I was making
making the decision to try to do my own self-employed.
because I was like, what's so much
scarier to me isn't the opposite.
without a safety net not having an alleged
reliably. You know, but I'm not.
better than everybody that like it's not reliable.
No, no.
That uh...
Like, what's happened?
Right, and so...
But it's also like it's not
the reliability, like the fog.
of reliability that you think you have isn't worth it.
the daily feeling of like I'm staring down.
the barrel of like another 30 years of
working out a place like this.
And like I
I need to make this switch now when it's easier.
than when it's gonna be later on,
'cause it's not gonna be later on.
It's not like our lives are gonna get less complicated.
Absolutely. And let me tell you, I resonate with that.
because when I picked up Alba-
and was ready to go.
That...
process, the decision took me a year.
decision took me three years, one by three years ago.
Right, right. So yeah.
Yeah, so the end and my life is much more complicated.
now I own a house. Now I own a really nice truck that is
to be painful to get rid of. Now, I've got
I look around and it's just like,
but I pay...
$8,000 for that camera, but I paid, you know,
know $3,000 for that TV.
And I'm at the point now where I'm just like,
and nobody's--
wants it so I'm going to give it away.
Yeah, life does certainly get more complicated.
Right.
- And you've got, you know, yeah.
your own stuff and kids and all that right to think about.
- Right.
right and like and then on top of all of
What's the economy gonna look like?
look like in the future.
if I've been able to figure out how to...
to do automation for an enormous amount of
when I've done my whole career up until this point.
like the illusion that
I should just know, just stay in a W-2 job.
where it's reliable and you get a salary and stuff like that.
It's like those jobs are not gonna fucking exist.
standing for. And that's another good reason that you're going
to be traveling and doing the things that you're doing,
because like--
major metropolitan areas in the United States.
are going to burn.
I'm like not even being that alarmist when I say it.
say that like New York, Los Angeles, Washington,
in DC, all of these places where there is a high come
concentration of knowledge workers, they are
are all going to lose their jobs in the next three years.
and the economy is going to die.
in those areas.
Like, you do not...
want to be hitching your wagon to a mama.
major metropolitan area because that places
It's like the way that did you right?
The way that Detroit has like gone to shit because of
manufacturing. Now it's going to be the opposite where
Major cities are going to ship because every city
single white collar worker who isn't like a VP.
above is going to happen.
job automated out from under them.
Great.
Right, and so you're positioning yourself to be the one.
and surfing on top of that.
- Yes.
like I want to be ahead of the curve because
- It's my, I don't want to be calling my pants down
and it's not.
just like a you know like oh there's an
new widget and now like my job gets automated in like a
small way. It's like literally every
single thing that I did on a computer can now be automated.
Like, that is existentially...
unnerving for somebody who relies on a
computer in order to be important.
- Well, so what?
What's the heavy thought through?
What happens to all of us?
those people. Dave.
They all lose. I mean they have to...
get jobs in the service sector. They have to
try to get jobs.
- Are we all of a sudden gonna have 50% of jobs?
of our population is going to be homeless.
Could be. Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know if they're literally going to be homeless,
but I do.
know that the standard of living for people who
are trained for white people.
color work is going to significantly drop.
going to collapse and those people are going to be able to.
has to do work that's below them.
Yes.
Beneath them, for sure.
And that is going to be--
struggle as well. So do you do
We end up with a universal basic income is what I was asking.
I don't know if the United States is gonna do that.
Obviously, we're going to need a president who doesn't just
go to war without talking to congress first before
we can write good reasons I'm sure.
He's a good man.
We just gotta trust him, right?
Yeah, just trust him.
Oh my God.
Is your brother saying that?
No, I don't talk politics with him.
That's a good idea.
Yeah, so...
Just, you know, the way that things are shitting.
But also I just didn't want to do the W2 thing anymore.
and it wasn't going to get any easier.
And I have been so much--
happier since then like I I
I started Prozac back in December because I absolutely...
have anxiety and depression that hadn't been treated for a very long time.
long time, but it really was only
after I left the job that I started feeling like...
like it was working because I just fell like...
I had this massive whale on my back.
And that's the thing with anxiety and depression is that they're
it is situational and chemical at the same time.
Yes. And so you do have to change your life.
Yes. So what, so how are you? How are you?
Are you finding business?
How are you making money?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I set out a couple of...
proposals last week and
They're both looking really good. I'm just staying in
in contact with people that I used to work with.
pretty much in discriminant
because the... the...
The variety of things that I can offer with what I'm trying to do.
to do with this business here is
Very broad. It's not limited just to business development.
Okay. So just to give you an example.
One of the people I worked with that I took
talk to and I send a proposal to she owns a company that
that manages and sells janitor
robots for big clots.
and like her company cleans the Cooper
Latino campus for Apple, for example.
Okay. And what?
With robot.
with robots. Yes. That's free.
Yes. And...
But she has to run a really lean up.
like everybody else wants to run a really clean operation.
So she's doing all the business development herself, but like she
He also has to physically go to the
buildings where she's trying to sell her robot
to so trying to like do
prospecting and lead generation and
all of the things that you have to do in order to develop revenue.
is conflicting with like what her actual excellency is.
expertise is in, but she's also not
getting success just like asking salespeople.
to do it for her. She needs a back.
And that is properly like running
her business development operation when she doesn't.
have to get involved. And so what I pitched her.
is you and I will talk. We will
create like you.
your vision for how you want to grow your company.
and I will create agents for you.
that will prospect for you, that will develop.
proposals for you that will essentially offer
I made all of the business development things that have nothing to do.
with human capital or judgment.
And then she will be able to just kind of.
of request. So those agents will
Will Prospect, will like agents as in...
a computer, a box, and other thing.
Yeah, yeah, they can prospect they can put
together a daily list of like here's all the leads.
that makes sense for you.
Like here's all the company.
that have a building that meets these criteria.
like you can get extremely granular with house
specific in jets and how it's doing that.
prospecting so that way you're not just like I want to call
every company in the S&P 500 today.
- Right.
Right, because they're not going to be big enough to be able to afford it.
right yeah see you up there yeah yeah I need to
call this company, this building.
in Dallas, Texas about this specific thing.
Here's the value proposition that is being generated
automatically that I can proactively send
that has all of the things that we would want to pay.
tailored automatically to this client.
And all of that can be general.
that's the best way to get a
better, better way to get a
interesting. So that's
- As well.
- How have you set your pricing?
How does that work?
I have three different options.
- But how does John know? - Like what?
What to set?
Yeah.
I mean...
Is it just like, I'll send you.
$100,000 package or is it a charge?
an hour or is it a charge? Right.
We're gonna have bucks.
an hour or. Yeah, it's so it's not hourly.
Basically what I was...
I was like, I want to just replace the income that I had.
my W2 job. Like I'm not trying to...
blow the doors off like I still do
one person but you're gonna but you're gonna.
So seriously, I mean, I think that this...
Yeah, I mean what happens if you make a million dollars?
next year. I'm not gonna be mad about it.
but like the way that I set up the problem.
pricing is like let's be realistic.
sick about like this is what I was making before this is
is what I'm going to try to make,
but because I'm self-employed.
Like,
I need a lot of buffer above what this is.
salary was before because of self employment.
I have to like procure our own insurance and shit like that.
So that is like the model that we have.
that I came up with.
It's essentially like, I need to get
at $350,000 of revenue.
in order to be able to replace the
I'll just say at the 164k I was making at my
last job. And so which is crazy.
that it's more than double the amount of salary
I had in order to replace.
But it's not surprising.
All right. That's kind of cool.
So in order to diversify what I'm offering and not
have it just be like an hourly like hey we're gonna you know
nickel and diamond you hear in there. It's like you get a four.
a six-week sprint and that's flat 55.
$500. Okay. And that is like.
like very scoped, very time box, very like...
constrained. I have a monthly review.
container model where it's 6,000 a month for a minimum of three.
for ongoing business development.
support and operations and maintenance for like all the
agents that I do and then I have a very high touch one.
that is based around
equity and game share that is really more for like
long-term engagements where they're like,
we don't...
I wanna pay you $7.00 like that, the whole game sure thing.
Yeah, yes.
And the equity thing.
Because that, that, that.
could make you super rich.
- Yes.
That's a good model.
Right. And it's the thing like you essentially go.
graduate, like start with the thing that
makes your CFO feel comfortable.
You're like, oh, 50.
$5,500. Yeah, our CEO found that in his couch the other day.
Yeah, of course. Right. Like start with that, but then.
you make yourself indispensable and potentially
get yourself to the point where a game share is an option.
So for that reason, I'm not prospecting...
major companies like all of these.
is like actually major publicly traded companies.
are really large ones they have their
own AI stuff. Like they don't need...
Me to come in to do it for them, but if you
sell the labor of people cleaning
it up? Like, you don't have it!
internal AI system.
Those are the organizations that I'm targeting.
I like it. Yeah, it feels very nichy.
It feels like you're found sort of the right groove.
I like it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
It basically gives me an excuse to just talk.
to people all day and which are good out.
I love that.
Yeah.
And
And I don't have a boss breathing down.
my nap and stuff like that and it's
Really at this point, it's just a matter of like how.
Good at using this technology can I give you?
yet so that I can make it.
different technology than than...
is sort of available to the public or is this that you just figured?
figured out how to do it better.
- So have you?
- You heard about vibe coding?
- No.
So, the way that you...
you would write code up until like two years.
years ago was you would have to know how to
right code. Ready? Right. Um.
And so in an app like Visual Studio,
that's where we're at.
like a software developer with type all of their gobbledygook.
and somehow make an app.
- Right.
you can embed your chat GPT.
the codecs into.
That same app, and I can just ask it to make
things for me. So I don't have to know how to
code, I just have to have the ideas.
Right.
And that is, you know, yeah, my, I got, I got.
friend up the road that's a computer engineer.
And every time I'm criticizing Chad GPT, I'm just like this.
This stuff is shit, like, that it puts out.
He's like an internet.
this is revolutionizing the world you got to understand and
And he says that.
I mean, his guys are using...
I think it is Church UPT. Yeah.
to write code. Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
And it's all ready.
- I didn't know you knew anything about.
or that whole world.
smart. I love it. Yeah, thank you. Yeah, I
don't know anything about code. Right. So it
It's just in the process of getting
This integrated in my computer and I'll just
quickly show you what it looks like because it doesn't look like
you beat TV like when you're, you know, on the browser and
They're asking questions and stuff.
To give you an example Spencer, I...
Had...
I got a proposal from the CEO.
and
wanted to...
Are you able to see what I'm seeing?
- Yep, yep.
Okay. Except my eyes can't quite make it out.
Yeah, it's it's neither here nor there. It's like this is the
interface. I'm not like...
I'm not doing anything in a browser. I'm not like sending ditch.
and then it's just like, oh, you're totally right.
Like this is what you should do.
instead like I am commanding my computer.
to do things that historically I would have to make.
I annually do myself.
- Right.
What I did here was, this is a bad example.
I'll rather than do this.
I will.
I'll just show you my website.
So I don't know how to write HTML.
However, this website that I made
which has a little game in it.
was completely coding.
using custom HTML. This is not square space.
This isn't like drag and drop, like make an easy peasy.
website. This is me telling my computer to
make a website for me.
Interesting.
And so this is just one example.
of you used to need to know how to
code in order to make something like this, but not
Now I can say, I want to...
have this kind of a branding.
I want to have
these colors and I want it to be
a dark background and a cover.
topics I want to have this
little like paper trail at the top that you can slide.
down and it shows your experience here. Look.
There's broad spire. - Sure.
And all of this stuff I
I just asked it to make it for me and...
I would look at it and I would give it revisions and I would look at it.
to give it revisions.
And basically, I put together
this website in two hours. That's crazy.
[ Silence ]
So like what this now means.
is that when I'm doing proposals for people, I'm not
not having to like go and copy my last thing and like make a couple
of tweaks I can say to my computer.
I have branding on my website already.
Can you please generate a proposal for this client?
based on this transcript that I'm sending you.
That is--
highly customized to what they are looking for. Please please
their logo from their website and feature it.
in the upper right corner and make it
It feel all of a piece with the body.
that I already have like.
- Interesting.
- I'm not.
having to handle any of this.
is just requests that I'm sending it.
fascinating. So at this
point it's not about like oh Chad should be tea help me right
this thing so that I can have text to put into a
another thing it's use the code that
you're writing chat GPT to create new
things. Right. That is
fascinating.
So then what you can do, the value of the value of the value of the value of the value
proposition that I'm having here is like if you can't
can automate an enormous amount of administrative
work. That means that's what eats into your mind.
margin is that you have overhead when you're
selling things and if you don't have
have the overhead anymore, then your margin
can get a lot bigger.
This is how to mitigate financial collapse.
future. Like that is what is going to have to happen.
No, this is what's creating financial collapse.
[laughs]
No totally!
It's not going anywhere though. That's the problem exactly
Exactly. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're surfing on top of it.
So, you it's
funny as you're saying this I'm just like I'm like all
Oh fuck, I'm like doing the equivalent of like stepping out of
of the work world like when cell phones were first new.
Right?
It's like fuck, like the technology is...
getting ready to go crazy and I'm gonna like be
completely irrelevant. I have to keep up with it in some other way.
I mean, you can do this on
you're out like you don't have to you don't have to have a business
I mean if you'd have to be okay in a part with 200.
dollars a month for Chad JupyT Pro, but other than that, like, you
You can just make all this shit on your own.
- That's crazy.
Well, not I want to right but like
If you had a reason to, where does that mean?
Maybe this is, yeah, this is sort of irrelevant
to what you're doing.
but it seems like they're like where...
It seems like somewhere along the line.
You know how an I heart
podcast they say guaranteed human.
Okay.
Yeah, is there tagline now?
There's going to be something there there is going to be something.
something somewhere along the line. And maybe this is the writer in me.
But that, I don't know.
that there's still gonna have to be...
I don't know for content and stuff like I like
Yes, a movie written by a, you know, a chap.
I don't want that.
I don't want that at all.
That's too.
Like, Vicki can't work right with shit.
And now all of a sudden she's putting out all this stuff.
And it's so clearly, I mean, it's just, it's just
garbage. Yeah shit. And I'm like
Really? Like your problems aren't any better than this?
I-
- Come on.
(laughing)
- Yeah, you got it.
iterate you gotta go back and forth you can't just take the fr-
thing that it gives you like yeah that's where the
time should be spent is being like, I
judge that this is not up to my human
standards, but you don't have to be.
The one who is physically hitting the buttons.
or understanding how to do that. Right. Yeah.
It's just what's in your head. If what is in your head is
very half baked and shitty, then it doesn't matter.
how fast an AI is.
is able to produce that for you. That's like
If you just go to Chad GPT and say, "Can I have a wag?"
website, like the first thing that it makes for you.
sucks, of course. So like you have to
to massage the bejesus out of it in order to
to get it to a point where like you would...
show it to anybody. Yeah.
And
And thinking about the big picture, it seems like now the...
The knowledge workers are going to have to become.
even that much more sophisticated or maybe it may be.
Maybe it's just a little bit of a different,
a different.
tooled a little bit differently. Right. Right. Because now...
now like good writing is valued.
because you know, a turn of phrase or whatever, but.
But maybe now it's going to be more about being.
more descriptive in yeah it and
and having a better vision.
And so then that's gonna be it.
a sort of divide, be the economic divide.
If.
It is at the point where if you are somebody
who is articulate in how you can write or
or how to explain what you want.
That is the differentiator between you and somebody else.
who's using AI. So they're going to be
the next. Yeah.
And like you said, if you have a writer in you, then...
And that's great.
You're safe.
Because...
You're going to have idea. I'm safe because I have piles of
money. I'm good.
Whatever works for you, but like
That is the thing that's gonna be value.
But if you made your...
whole career out of like I'm the guy
who can pull the lever.
Even if--
it's not like a like like the most esoteric and
confusing in niche leverage.
if it was happening on a computer.
that doesn't matter anymore.
Right. So.
Yeah, it genuinely is like
Like the Mark Zuckerbergs of the world took over 30 years.
starting 30 years ago.
And now they have created something that makes it.
so that the versions of that
who are starting out are completely irrelevant.
Right.
And so it's
The power in the world is gonna go back to the...
people who can think outside of the box. Right.
which it always has been.
If you think about it, right?
It's the inventors.
It's the--
entrepreneurs. Right. Yeah.
Another reason to not be in the W2.
to threshing machine because like.
If you're not there to be somebody who's got big ideas or...
Or if you're at a place where they're like, "Fuck your ideas."
then like you gotta get out of there because
because you're going to lose your job eventually.
Right.
totally. Boy that gives me that yeah that gets my head
spending a little bit. Yeah.
Yeah, man, that's the way that things are going.
It's...
Nicky and I were talking about it this weekend.
We were like, we gotta talk about something else.
the shit is scary.
Like, right?
What about
What do you think with anthropic in the Pentagon?
Right. I'm very queasy about
having Chad GPT decide with you.
you live or die?
Yeah, because now OpenAI is--
Is making the murder bots murder.
It's a little frightening, although...
On the other hand, you know, when...
you know, when like I almost ran into that car the other day.
and my truck stopped itself.
- Ah.
right? So then then then I'm like, oh, I get it like this.
thing can drive better than I can.
I look down to grab my coffee and I'm, you know,
swerving out of the lane and it brings me back.
Right? So yeah.
Right? There's something there.
Right. Like, where?
Where does human judgment matter?
It doesn't.
What you're doing is not going to be a bad guy.
What you don't want a human to do is to make legal decisions for you.
You don't want it to make emotional decisions for you.
like that's where the human in the loop needs to come in.
That's where you start.
start seeing AI psychosis where people are like,
completely allowing themselves to be driven.
and literally and figuratively by...
AI or like you're not deciding anything
for yourself. Like that is...
That is dangerous, but...
If you can decide like where does my judgment
actually matter the most, then.
That is like what can make you excel instead of just like a...
Oh, well I know how to like hype really well.
Right. Doesn't matter. Yeah, breathe new.
world for sure. Yes.
Yeah, I'm glad I'm in the hospital.
I'm glad I'm in the hospital.
invested in these companies.
Yeah, that are going to crush everybody's jobs.
Yeah, you should talk to it while I'm doing it.
you are 100% up on this with your financial advisor.
like, "Hi, like, who should I not be investing in right now?"
- Right.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, let's...
Let's think about there though, because I think about like...
I got a poor dumb friend.
in Albuquerque who I was visiting.
with over Christmas and he was just like oh my god.
this economy sucks, it's so terrible, you know, I can't believe
And I was just like, "What? The economy's dark."
It's fantastic what are you talking about?
And then I realized, oh shit.
like I've become one of them, right?
- Yeah, sort of the... (laughs)
And as much as I'm happy to...
one of them it seems like um this
There's something about how society is very much bifurge.
that I think is
is unsustainable.
in his tragic, but honestly.
I mean, it's turning into, I know that you're not.
big movie guy but like Blade Runner? You're familiar with Blade Runner and
what that looked like.
- Yeah, I saw it once, I wanna say yeah.
Right, like the wealthy people?
People are living an enormous luxury.
And everybody else is just scraping shit.
at the bottom. Yeah, yeah. Like the, the, the gap.
The app is going to keep on happening.
Yeah, it's super sad.
It's people like...
you who were like, "I'm gonna let my money make."
money for me.
Right.
Like, that's why he-
you can feel like this economy is really good,
because if you're--
If you've been doing that, then you're doing really well.
- Well, but if you're like, I have a,
I have a job in a bank account.
And like, that's what money is to me? Then...
Yeah, your buddy in Albuquerque is probably that person.
Yeah, yeah, and then like
Like I was talking to my tutor too, you know, my tutor.
from Columbia. Yeah, I forget what I said.
And sometimes I'm just like Spencer shut the fuck up like
shut the fuck up because like like
You know, I'm worried about, I don't know what,
and he's just like,
dude like what are you talking about?
It's being, you know, so yeah.
Yeah.
We need some equity in the world.
We need some...
Bernie in the world, right? Yeah, yeah, seriously
Well, I...
It's been great catching up with you.
I'm super excited for you.
- Even said they're safe, right?
- I'm in a right of travel blog or something.
once I get my shit together. I don't think I'm in.
I don't think I'm gonna vlog because I don't...
I don't know.
know that just feels weird. Yeah I mean if
If you can write, the people who've logged are the ones who are like...
I don't know how to write anything.
So I'm just gonna--
- Well, I think I know.
- I'm not right, but I don't, but I'll get there.
I'm sure you're a lot closer than most other people are.
No, no, no, no.
One last thing I wanted to run by you.
You were talking about how Mark knew.
somebody who is going to be doing like like sales.
operations.
Right.
I
don't want to be and obviously I'm not trying to be in
an employee of fucking Crawford and company.
However...
I might reach out to Mark and be like, "Hey!"
Have you considered automating the shit out of it?
Wow!
Oh, like you have this.
vacuum that is left by this person who
by all rights, you should have been the one.
who was doing it.
That is not a bad idea actually.
I don't know if you've met Mark, but he's he's
young enough to sort of have
those kind of ideas.
Yeah, I think he might he'd be open to listening to it anyway
Yeah, I'll just talk to him.
Yeah, he seems to be super priced since...
of these days, like I can't get him to spend like 50 grand on.
on some software that we desperately need.
And...
when we start talking about spending 100.
or something, he's just like, oh, I don't know.
So--
Yeah, but it sounds like your pricing is is reasonable.
of all so. That's kind of the those are the
organizations I'm undercutting.
Right.
pay yearly for 25 seats on this
thing and you got to give us 50 to 100.
grand. Like you pay me $5,500.
once and then you get to just view
the thing going forward. Right, right.
So yeah, so yeah
I would think.
I don't, I don't.
Well, yeah, you'd have to have that conversation.
with them about what could be automated, but yeah, I mean, I think.
- Yep.
- There's, there's tasks.
that the sales executive needs to be doing on a regular basis.
based on somebody needs to be managing now making sure
that they're doing it.
There's maybe even
sort of summarizing and understanding what they're
doing and making sense of that so that Mark and
stands out. Who knows. I mean basically what
what you can do is a salesperson could
have a discovery call or whatever.
And you can send the transcript to an email
box and it will automatically update your CRM.
based on the information that was in the transcript.
Mark would you get interested in that?
for sure.
Right, cause getting sales people to click
buttons on a computer has been the
the book bear of the entire business industry.
since it started. Right. Right. You can't get those fuckers.
to click anything. So like, but they'll tell you.
talk a lot. So how can you harness that?
part. Right. And then and
everybody's happy. Yeah, yeah totally.
Totally. And that is a problem for sure.
We have like one sales person that actually keeps up their CRM.
Do I know them?
Yes.
Who's good at it?
It's Melissa.
- Oh, okay, yeah.
- Yeah, imagine.
The craziest one. Yeah, yeah, yeah. She's such a pain in the eye.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry. (laughs)
- She's...
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll bridge that somewhere.
But I think you're perfect.
Yeah, so happy.
Thank you.
Thank you for watching, and I'll see you in the next video.
I don't want to hear.
Yeah, perfect. Right.
right right right right right and and.
and won't guilt her me and all that stuff.
Yeah.
and we will be the first to speak.
[inaudible]
I need to be done.
I think they need to be done.
(mumbles)
It happened. It happened.
That'd be fun.
[inaudible]
[unintelligible]
(mumbles)
Thank you.
[inaudible]
But knowing us, we're gonna hire a 60 year old because of
That's what we do.
And we need to stop that.
I know.
Yeah, we just hired some old chick to be
a sales person. I'm just like, Mark, what are you doing? Like...
I don't know, bring in somebody sexy, bring in some...
Big boobs or something. I don't know
expect to make any money.
I guess we'll have to stay upright. Right?
Absolutely. Exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's true.
Okay, great. Yeah.
catching up.
Yes, I will
I'll, uh, I'll, uh, I'll, uh, I'll, what's happening from, uh,
from Columbia when I'm there.
Exactly.
Cool. I'll take a good talk in here. We'll see you.
All right.